big tech companies try to control what
you see online of course but they also
try to control what you don't see a new
report a shocking one from Breitbart
exposes the existence of a Google
blacklist for quote controversial
YouTube queries questions you ask on
YouTube trying to find videos the most
flagrant abuse not surprisingly concerns
abortion after receiving a complaint
from a political activist posing as a
reporter at slate.com there are a lot of
those google intervened to bury pro-life
videos on YouTube and replace them in
search with pro-abortion videos for
example videos by abortionist turned
pro-life activists anti-latino were
buried displaced by pro-abortion content
from BuzzFeed and CNN well in a
statement YouTube denied doing anything
wrong and said any shifts were purely
due to their algorithms of course we're
controlled by people robert f scene has
spent a lot of time looking into this
question he's a senior research
psychologist at the American Institute
for behavioral research and technology
and he joins us thank you very much for
coming on you were the first person I
thought of when I read this story
because you have done I think the
cutting edge research into the effect of
search Google search and other digital
platforms on human behavior and
political behavior so what kind of
effect could this sort of distortion
have on an election well Tucker would
have a devastating effect and you know
as you know I am NOT a conservative I do
I I love America I love democracy and I
think we should all be rising above our
politics here and recognize the extreme
danger that we're facing when a company
like Google can basically censor
anything it wants to censor now this new
set of leaks is extraordinary because it
confirms things that I and others have
been saying in writing for years it
confirms number one that individual
employees at Google have the power to
manually
remove material remove content that we
see and they do so often with political
ends and number two this tells us that
sundar Pichai a Google CEO committed
perjury when he testified before
Congress a few weeks ago because he said
quite specifically that Google never
does this so I mean I my frustration
levels are so high I don't want to take
it out on you but the first thought is
well why isn't he being recalled back to
Congress to explain himself or face
charges because you're not allowed to
commit perjury but my question is can
any of us trust that the next election
won't be swayed dramatically in one
direction by interference from the tech
companies I guarantee you that this past
election was affected I'll be releasing
some some data on this I hope an early
March
that'll make the point beyond any doubt
I also just published a piece in which I
showed that just one manipulation on
Google's part on Election Day their go
vote reminder that one reminder that go
vote reminder shifted between 800,000
and 4.6 million votes to democratic
candidates on election day in 2018 so
why why isn't this the hacking of our
democracy I mean how can you have a
democracy under these circumstances
well democracy is a kind of illusion at
this point because we have let these
companies Google more than any other go
completely wild there are no rules no
regulations no laws that restrict
anything they do and again the more one
looks at what it is they're actually
doing and these new leaks help a lot in
my opinion the closer one looks at what
they're doing the more outraged one
should become and I want to emphasize we
should all be outraged
not just conservatives I agree I hope
that what you just said
Ping's around the internet unimpeded and
winds up in the inbox of every member of
Congress on both sides Robert thank you
very much my pleasure always